and joining us is jonathan breiler he's
the ceo of offgem hello to you mr breely
so you're changing the rules explain
that to us
well let me start by saying i know how
many families are struggling with the
huge change in energy prices that we've
seen now off gem is working very hard to
make sure that no one pays any more than
they need to for their energy costs what
we're announcing today is the price cap
that regulation that makes sure you
don't pay more than you need to for your
energy is updated more frequently so
we're going to change the price cap
every three months from october instead
of every six months as we used to and
the reason we're doing that is to make
sure that people pay a fair price for
their energy but also that companies can
manage in what is an incredibly volatile
market so yes it will go up as prices go
up but it will come down equally quickly
as prices come back down
but you acknowledge mr really do that if
this had been in place previously then
our bills would have gone up before this
april rise that we've seen now
well remember that the total cost you
pay over the year would be absolutely
the same because that reflects that only
the cost of the energy that we buy but
as i say yes the price would go up more
quickly as prices go up but equally
importantly as those prices come down
then the price cap comes back down again
i remember back in the 2010s when people
saw their prices go up and were waiting
and wondering why prices didn't come
down equally quickly the good thing
about the price cap is we will make sure
it only reflects cost and therefore it
only reflects what you need to pay for
your energy
but it is a bit swings and rounds device
isn't it because as we made the point
there which you've conceded that the
price that we've seen this big jump that
we've seen in april we would have seen
that earlier than that if we had had
these checks every three months
well you would have seen that earlier
but that would have been moderated so it
wouldn't necessarily have been as large
a jump as we saw in april but the main
point is under any circumstances the
price cap will always be there to make
sure no one pays any more than they need
to for their energy the important thing
here is to make sure we have a market
that adapts to what is a very very
different global situation particularly
with the russian invasion of ukraine so
our job is to make sure the market is
resilient the market can manage but most
importantly customers pay no more than
they need to for their energy so this
announcement is really part of a much
bigger program to make sure we can
manage through what is an incredibly
tough time for customers and a turbulent
time for the industry now our job as i
say is to make sure we look after
customers interests and make sure people
pay no more than they need to
yeah do you acknowledge that it's going
to get tougher before it gets better
well unfortunately and i've said this
publicly on a number of occasions now
with the russian invasion of ukraine we
are seeing a sustained increase in
further increase in gas prices so the
difficult news i have it is likely in
october that prices will go up again but
what we will do is we will make sure you
pay no more than the cost that you need
to for your energy and we're not going
back to the bad old days where unfair
profits were charged by the retailers on
top of that
uh so is that a yes things are going to
get worse before they get better
so yes things are going to get tougher
as far as we can see it's not certain
the market is changing dramatically
almost day by day but we you know we
have to warn customers to expect further
price rises in october
um
we're at mickey's house today i don't
know if you've managed to uh watch any
of the program mr beasley i'm sure
you're very busy um she has a
pre-payment meter when that runs out she
has to light candles to uh try to light
the house what would your advice be to
her and other people who are living here
in wigan
look i know this is an incredibly tough
time for customers and i talk to
customers almost every week to make sure
i do understand what people are going
through our advice is simple please do
proactively get in touch with your
energy company there is help advice and
support that's available there are
amazing organizations who can support
you through this difficult time help you
understand how to manage your energy
bills and really help you through what
is an unprecedented set of circumstances
so get in touch with your company get
access to all the support that's
available and make sure you get the
advice that you need we also say to
families look if you are facing trouble
with your energy bills you may want
wider financial advice to make sure you
can manage all of the different issues
around the cost of living so far but to
emphasize we know this is difficult for
families we know this is difficult for
customers we're doing everything we can
to make sure that you pay a fair price
for your energy
okay it's good to talk to you